scientists in south africa were the
first to raise alarms about omicron and
virologists in this lab have been
leading the way on researching the fast
spreading variant
the very has been studied in south
africa longer than has been studied in
in other places and this lets us
understand it better and enables us to
kind of inform the rest of the world
these researchers are pooling their
findings with results from other labs
around the world and a clearer picture
of omicron's characteristics has begun
to emerge
they say the strain possibly causes
milder symptoms but is more resistant to
vaccines and more infectious early data
suggests that omicron is more
transmissible than delta with a doubling
time of about two days
as the variant poses a challenge for
governments everywhere we visited this
lab to understand what scientists have
learned about omicron
alex seagal and his team of virologists
tested the new strain of the virus
against the pfizer shot so i'm preparing
the cells for infection tomorrow okay so
it all starts in here
their analysis showed that the variant
can partially evade protection from
vaccines or prior immunity the fact that
it's more likely to infect people who
are vaccinated but it's less likely to
cause serious illness compared to the
other variants is exactly what we see
in our work as well their research
predicted that for people who have been
vaccinated effectiveness against
infection is 35
compared with 72 for people who have
been vaccinated and who have immunity
from a prior infection
these findings were roughly in line with
another recent real world study
but it's difficult to draw broad
conclusions from south africa which
compared with europe and the us has a
younger population
it also has a relatively low vaccination
rate as compared with places like the uk
while there's still limited data
seagal's team has also observed that
symptoms from this strain might be less
severe
another group of researchers in south
africa found that even though the number
of cases is rising the risk of infection
of hospital admission for infected
people is 29 lower compared with the
first wave in 2020. so far the
infections have been mild mostly mild
here and there might be several reasons
for that one reason
is there's a lot more pre-existing
immunity there are a lot more people who
are previously infected
with the different variants before
omicron came on the scene and also a
considerable number of people now in
south africa who were vaccinated that
wasn't here before but there might be
other reasons perhaps the virus itself
is a little bit different
this
we don't know yet
even if the variant might be less
virulent the sheer number of cases could
still lead to a surge in
hospitalizations as the strain seems to
be far more transmissible than others
for a variant like omicron it's kind of
a frankenstein's monster of mutation
it's heavily mutated what that means is
it gains certain abilities
one of these abilities is to escape from
an immune response to a previous
infection or to vaccination
and the second ability is to transmit
better that's prompting governments in
the us and europe to accelerate rollouts
of booster shots
early studies have suggested that
another pfizer shot will increase
protection against omicron but the
majority of the world still hasn't been
fully vaccinated and south africa only
begins its rollout of booster shots in
january
global leaders are now weighing the
evidence as they decide what policies to
implement and how to best protect their
populations everybody is of course
worried and they want to predict what is
going to happen
so it's it's a very much a globalized
effort now in south africa we happen to
have a very good research community for
infectious disease and we're able to
make a lot of progress
because also it started here before
elsewhere and be able to say something
to the rest of the world and give some
predictions